your first set of the night Legend of
kill Tony one of the greatest regulars
of all time the international touring
act selling out everywhere literally has
a
I think in New York City Make some noise
for Hans Kim everybody
60 seconds uninterrupted
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
as you can tell by my confidence I'm
dating a white woman
it's pretty impressive for me it's like
one of you guys getting into Harvard
I love being in a relationship because
now when I have sex I feel like I
deserve it
no one's entitled to sex but if you yell
at me on the phone for two hours I'm
gonna stick my dick in something
I love how gen Z are so [__] up
nowadays that they won't even watch porn
unless you call it an unboxing video
[Music]
[Laughter]
to convince them my dick was a vape
laughs
yeah it's Oriental passion fruit
I don't know why they call it racial
slurs because I enunciate
thank you
Hans Kim with yet again proving that he
does a lot better when his job is on the
line
I've been really stressed out Tony I
grew a stressed pimple on my chin ah oh
okay
so I might start a union for the
regulars so that we don't have to get
challenged well no one none of the other
regulars are getting challenged I don't
think they'll join the union a couple
are mentally challenged but uh not
challenge so how'd you prepare for this
this week why do you what's your process
to have a better minute every time your
job is on the line compared to last week
when you uh struggled in front of post
Malone and Joe Road
um probably like stressing out and just
uh hating myself and reading internet
comments and then writing based on hate
wow
there you go the life of a comedian
people wonder why we all kill ourselves
there's a little insight
what else has happened this week with
you how's the white girlfriend doing the
white is doing great white
great white
I accidentally got her sunburned in L.A
uh uh had to spread aloe vera on her
um she's great I uh I'm kind of worried
about her because she turns on the dome
light to look at her phone I think she
might be stupid
[Music]
oh my goodness you think she might be
stupid that is so funny uh all right
Hans you feel good about it yes okay put
the mic and the mic stand we're gonna
you guys have anything for Hans anything
like that
um yeah one thing I love about Hans is
when the pressure is on [__] you show
up [__] thank you David use a Chinese
Diamond you were made
I'm Korean
of South Korea my bad dog
I don't know man I grew up in the South
[__] I only know white and black [__]
anything other than that it's Asian
[__] you fall up under that category
you've called him every slur except the
correct one
[Laughter]
so how Chinese people is B uh it's like
that right there
that's a restaurant
no we have kimchi oh [__] that kimchi
cookies kimchi fortunes I don't know
sorry
Hans get scared when he looks in my eyes
outside
I love it Hans great minute let's see
what happens thank you uh go back there
we're gonna have you come back out in
just a minute oh yeah because I didn't
mention the audience actually decides
who wins so his opponent tonight doing a
new 60 seconds uh we met him only once
he just moved here he performed last
week and uh we said we want to see you
challenge Hans Kim ladies and gentlemen
Make some noise for Scott Fillmore
everybody here he is his second time on
kill Tony his second minute his second
week in Austin Texas come on make some
noise for Scott film where everybody
let's go
ah man this is nuts uh it's crazy man I
I'm gay you're welcome it's uh it's my
gift uh but I've decided it's time for
me to start dating chicks again uh it's
mostly because I'm tired of women
feeling safe around me
don't like it
yeah man I don't know it's weird there's
there's so much focus on what divides us
as a country you know like we put our
labels on gay straight whatever I don't
like that you know I just read that 80
of Americans have depression something
in common that's good you know like my
gay depression your straight depression
the only difference is my bite marks go
farther down on the shotgun barrel than
yours do
[Applause]
I don't know man
yeah it's uh that yeah that's all I got
thanks guys
all right Scott Fillmore 53 seconds in
and out uh very fun how do you feel
Scott
step up to that microphone that uh
picks up the uh this is this is great
yeah you guys are fun
absolutely so how's your uh you're been
here for two weeks is that right one
week yesterday right one week yesterday
so how's Austin Texas been treating you
so amazing dude it's uh great shows good
people everybody's been really cool and
uh I I want to kill myself every time I
walk outside I hate it wait why do you
want to kill yourself because I'm Fat
Tony oh and it's hot so hot here right
it is it's so hot it is extra hot for
you David Lucas if you kill it
foreign
you can't kill yourself in a regular
rope that ceiling fan coming down [__]
I'm an eagle scout I'm good with knots
man I'll be all right I'll be fine you
look like an unpaid Chris Farley yo
[Applause]
I don't know how you I don't know how
you were scared of the microphone you'd
be sucking dick don't you
oh
[Music]
[Laughter]
that thing act like he's scared of [__]
that look like that [__] get your ass
out of here
I know you're new to Gay Culture but I'm
what's called a top Lucas
how you on top with that belly [__] you
gonna bounce off [__]
teach me your secrets dude teach me your
secrets however you do it I'll do it you
try to hit another game [__] from the
back you're gonna bounce into the
ceiling [__]
that [__] gonna be like a pogo sticky
you just tell me you you don't [__] at
all then that's what you're saying I go
missionary that's what fat [__]
that's a sight to see holy [__] but you
can't
[Music]
let's go let's do it wow I'm not [__]
you boy
all talk dude all talk I don't know I
think you're out here giving me advice
tips you're not gonna follow through
dude come on man
I'm talking about women I don't know I
think David's about two Tequilas away
from doing it
bartender we're gonna
have a whole new episode of two bears
two caves
[Laughter]
all right all right Hans Kim get back
out here uh make so much for Hans Kim
everybody it makes so much for Scott
Fillmore what a way to start tonight's
show and now things will get a little
bit crazier oh we have a little absentee
vote look at this ah this guy really
taking advantage of the moment right now
what a great time to go pee
how exciting he looks like a Blink 182
and 911 had a baby I love it get in
there yes very cool you have little tiny
middle fingers go pee dude
all right here we go
how many of you have Scott Fillmore
winning tonight and becoming the new
regular on kill Tony
foreign
it's up to you guys how many of you
think Hans Kim retains and Remains the
regular I mean that's just
it's not even close folks the
[__] knows when to turn it on he
had more punch lines uh in the minute no
doubt about it Hans Kim everybody makes
noise for Scott Fillmore
having the best week of his life
probably one of the last weeks of his
life as well
because he's fat he's
morbidly obese
just a reminder he really tried me Tony
with that gate with that can I say gay
on him you can say guys you think the
Gay's the worst thing you've said so far
are you insane
he really tried me bro what the hell
I like women not boys
did he really just say did you really
just say can you say gay on this show do
you know you've probably said gay more
than anybody else ever you've called me
a gay everything
I don't know bro but when it's an actual
gay person up here you know they take
that [__] different yeah Them [__] be
United like 300 [__] they be out here
I don't know if you can call them
n-words oh yeah they might like that
[__] man they don't like to identify as
what they is so they might like being
called in work Joe DeRosa this is I just
want to see how far he can dig with this
this is wild anything can happen like
Joe to Rosa your forehead identifier
[Laughter]
your forehead took a trip to Brazil for
a BBL [__]
hold this for a second what is that all
this that's a regular size book you fat
[__]
[Applause]
if you had butter [__] you're going to
prison for life [__]
oh [__] all right you guys say but we
got all night we got all night Hans how
do you feel you did it again how many
wins is this you suspended your throne
how many times I'm 5-0 I defeated a gay
a Mexican
a woman two retards
unbelievable
unbelievable I'm one trans person from
an infinity stone
[Music]
Hans Kim you're a [__] Legend no
better way to make the show started than
with you
he's all over the world now he's a
global act that was Hans Kim all right
now I pulled the name out of the bucket